i want to read a story from the book
okay it's pretty crazy story you got
here in the book and i have a feeling
the audience is going to have the chills
all over their body when i read this
so there are no points every one of them
is number one similar to relentless
i'm not going to be able to get any
points but this is one of the number one
points okay
so you say on page 103 winning
wants all of you there is no balance and
balance you know is a very
uh trending topic it's not healthy to
not live a balanced life it's not
healthy to do this
but here's a story you tell when my
daughter was around five years old she
was watching me pack for a long
road trip and she asked daddy why do you
have to travel so much
this is how i take care of our family i
told her i travel for my work so i can
care for
care take care of you and mom and put
food on the table
she was quiet for a moment and then she
said the words that stung me harder than
anything
that has ever been said to me if i
eat less can you stay home more
holy freaking moldy
damn oh dude
i read this i was like i was just kind
of like
shaken by it my daughter you know same
age when you're telling she's about to
turn five years old
how do you explain this to the average
guys like well that's why you should
stay that's why you shouldn't work that
hard that's why you shouldn't go after
ten what are you doing
is that really a good father are you
really doing the right thing are you
wanting to go through the pain
why don't you just kick back a little
bit why don't you just relax a little
bit
and the next part of that like i said
most people would be like okay
the story would be yes i unpacked i
decided to stay
i kept packing i kept
i kept packing
you need to be true to yourself and
here's the thing
i knew what what she was asking i knew
what she was going through
but i i had to be selfish during that
time
and i had the only reason i had to be
selfish at during that time is
because i had a path and a goal that i
wanted her to be able to achieve and her
to be able to see
and knowing that i had to make the
sacrifice
now for the benefit of what was going to
deliver
down the line and if i couldn't deliver
what i wanted to deliver down the line
it would actually be more detrimental
to myself and to the family and to my
growth and
her growth
if i didn't complete what i was set out
to complete
did she read this chapter she hasn't
they have i have not allowed them to
read the chapter yet
really yeah is this the same daughter
you're about to go visit or is this
this the same daughter you're about to
go visit so
the topic of guilt okay i want to spend
a couple minutes talking about the topic
of guilt i made a video like two months
ago
talking about guilds because it it
messes with people last night i met the
breakers guy comes up to me says patrick
i gotta talk to him and i gotta talk to
you i gotta talk that so what's that he
says i'm a real estate developer
i'm killing it i'm making millions i'm
doing so well for myself
i married my wife she's my sweetheart
i'm 27 years old i'm doing everything
and everything i can
but i got a six-month-old daughter that
just came and i'm going through this and
i'm going through that how do you manage
this because my wife is a stay-at-home
mom and she's trying to take care of the
kid but at the same time i feel like i'm
overworking and real estate and working
success all this stuff that he's telling
me right
in my mind i'm listening to this guy and
i'm asking myself first of all
there is no right answer i can give this
guy well you can't teach that if you're
asking it
whatever answer you give the guy's
already asking for permission to say
what he's just asking for permission is
what he's doing right
we're saying hey make me feel good that
i work less and stay home and kick back
and relax
i'm like i don't have an answer for you
buddy this is not a decision i make for
you no
this is a decision you're gonna make
right how do you process the concept of
guilt
with people who you get to a certain
level
and you're working hard you're like oh i
can compete with this level guys and
this is great and i'm going to go to the
next level
then you go to the next like okay six
months ago yeah
i can beat these guys as well then you
go to the next level
and you're like i don't know about this
level i think at this level i'm okay
being in the
top 20 percent by there's no to be in
the top one percent of this level that
guy does that that guy does this this
guy does that
i'm backing off right do you think that
is a decision the individual has to make
or do you think that is a decision that
somebody can be sold on by somebody else
most of the time that decision somebody
else is sold on by somebody else
that that you're deci to stop the
question i'm asking about the guild side
is the following i'm asking
a guy's come in he wants to be a killer
right
but he's hit the wall where he's
experiencing similar guilt to the story
you talk about in page 104
yeah so he's coming to you and he's
saying
look here's what i'm going through with
tim you know i remember that story you
said on 103 i'm kind of going through
this what do you think about this this
is that
versus the guy who's a michael or kobe
or this he already
knows it by the way it doesn't mean it's
not painful it doesn't mean you're not
gonna have an emotional it doesn't mean
you're not gonna cry about it it doesn't
mean you get in the car
but is it the individual's decision or
is somebody else gonna sell you on
don't worry about it go think big go
after it it's an excellent decision
it's yourself it's the individual
decision it's an individual decision
all right listen there's guilt that
other people put on you
the worst guilt is you put on yourself
all right everybody every single
decision
there's so much guilt that tribe people
people try to put
not only are you working so much why do
you need to go work out
you're going to eat that why are you
dressed that way everybody's all
those are all that's just people's way
of do of laying guilt on you all right
so people are going to be constantly
laying guilt on you
it's the guilt you put on yourself you
make a decision to be this is
this is who i'm going to be this is who
i am this is
this is the person this is the person
and these are the consequences that come
with
being this person
how do you have that conversation guy
asked me a question yesterday i'm
sitting there another guy comes sits
right next to my wife we're having a
dinner at this place called echo and she
asked well how do you deal with your
husband that's working like this all
this other stuff
how do you have that conversation but
believe it or not most people don't know
how to have this conversation right
right
how do you have that conversation
because many times if you don't have
this conversation this leads to merit
you know this leads to issues with
friends with family with mom with that
falling out all this other stuff
from your experience i haven't been
around for a while you got wisdom in
this more than we do because
you're the expert in this area what is
the right approach to take with the
people you love the most your wife your
mom your dad your kids
have the conversation early have the
conversation often
but results have to dictate
what you're doing that's it if you if
you tell
somebody i need 90 days you got 90 days
to deliver don't turn
five years later and say you didn't
deliver in 90 days
if you say hey i need five years this is
where i'm going
you better you better deliver in those
five i told michael
i said i need 30 days
i need 30 days before you before you
make any judgment
on the training anything that's going on
i need 30 days
30 days turn into 15 years
all right so when you tell those
individuals those
and those results have to not only
benefit you they have to benefit
them they have to benefit them
all right and everybody thinks about
benefiting them it just means you know
from a financial step no it's not a
it's not only a financial standpoint if
you're putting in
all this time now all right
then when you do take that trip with the
family and you do that
you're in that trip with that family
you're like you're you're like you've
earned you've earned that time you've
earned that time to be
you've earned that time to be with them
when i was
when my daughter was younger
i would move to l.a to train
colby that was one of those required
goes i need you i need you to live here
so i would and my daughter was a
volleyball player
i said give me the volley give me the
volleyball schedule all right
and this is now from flying in from
orange county
so i would look at the volleyball
schedule i would look at
kobe's schedule from a workout training
game schedule i would look at it
i would literally catch
a 7 a.m flight from orange county
land in chicago go to my daughter's
volleyball game
for 90 minutes drive back to the airport
get on the 7 30 flight back
and be ready for the training session
next day wow
how long did you do that how long was
that run seven years
wow buddy good for you man what a
freaking story right there
seven years now did i make every game
no
did i miss events i did miss events was
it a perfect situation
no does it come with the territory it
does
unfortunately it does you know do do you
almost tell somebody who like let's just
say i come to and i said tell him let me
tell you
i'm not scared of these guys i want to
go compete with these guys and i believe
i got what it takes
i'm six six i got a 43 inch vertical
leap i got a good size mitt i got a good
quick first step i'm an 81 free throw
shooter in college
i'm a 48 field goal shoot i'm pretty
good at my game i'm good i'm a guy
that's coming up i think i can play well
with these guys
if i come to you do you tell me you sure
you're going to be okay with this
you sure you're going to be okay with
that are you sure you want to handle
this you sure you're going to be
accepting the fact that
you know parents not going to support
you how do you handle are you enter
is there an interview process or all the
all the whole things you know everybody
has it's it's like okay
this is what i'm going to do and this is
what i'm willing to do
do those things match you know everybody
likes to tell you yeah i want to be the
best on this this this i tell all the
people i said all the time
i get that listen i'll i'll outwork
anybody i'll do anything i'll do this
and i'll say okay
i'll see you tomorrow for the workout
what time's the workout i need you here
at 3 30 in the morning
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye